[Music]
so this is the bots outward Kisuke late
centers gonna come in he's going to tilt
and then it's not that his hip goes out
but his head comes this way there's like
same exact same exact so dislike comes
in and he goes straight back out so I'm
gonna push he's not going in straight
back out secondly I'm not the one
pushing there he's running into me he
runs into me he goes into that so it's a
timing you come like this you're gonna
end up clashing on that elbow so he
comes in they guide this coming in okay
my body has to do something different
than yours I can't go like this that's
not going to be the pattern
my father has to go behind and rotate
this lie
[Music]
to make sure my arms not collapsing okay
class on the over so I'm just imagining
I match it watch it watch it
draw see the quarter is stopping and her
body's going through you see that's the
time
don't push it past that point you
understand there's sometimes when you
feel some of your like yeah okay and not
even get greedy and you go like this
don't do that just let it let it draw
stop and wait for the geometry do its
job
[Music]
don't go here you got laughing Walter
don't do that
[Music]
so at this point he's standing you see
you see so if I stop him here and make
contact then all this has to be young
but if it's yummy he can't overpower he
has more young the reason why we NZ is
young okay there is a place where a time
you wear this I just leave that there
just leave that there
do you see that don't I'm not letting it
go right just leave it there okay and
his energy I'm going to let go now he
wants to go forward okay I'm gonna let
it go forward but on a turn okay so I'm
let go around that corner he's always
gonna go wrong and around and come back
out so he's gonna he goes around so I've
never made his elbow go backwards in its
motion
I keep extending it forward with my body
movement do you get it it's not my cat
go with my hands a cap toe in my head
it's not always one now I can't go like
this you see but how I move when I move
to where I move creates a pattern so
it's not that my hardest
like this you see that see my hat but
watch watch my body my body is doing it
do you see that okay so that's what I do
in my body you guys see that
so you'll feel that you'll feel it
whoo well that's telling you I'll try
going with my body you'll feel that now
if I go with my body so you can't drop
with your finger you gotta keep all like
this is not the technique okay trying to
get all of that pattern that happens
here is happening off the back foot okay
so that's where you are so you can't
push it
he's just rounding
do you understand so I have to have that
same thing on the other side
not that I'm linearly thrusting I would
be wrong it's accumulated he's here and
he's pushing and he's just rounding he's
just rounding me
[Music]
this is very much different than this
lurch step you're taking so the main
difference is that your line of gravity
is between your two feet you see and
when he had when the guy's vinegar or
has a great deal of energy that staffs
is never coming down on big people and
that's where some of you guys are there
you let the energy out of the arm you
see more do you have to take a little
step remember those things okay well
your energy is on the back foot
[Music]
is the grounding single vector he's
pushing and you're just here and that's
going to rock out now this will just
read the move you see that it's not
pushing the gas and trying to force
women down forget it
little baby DDP are you trying to hurt
you this you should not be entering into
y'all space does everyone understand
that if I'm doing eg me there's a good
space there so there should be nothing
tuition on the depth of my stacks
okay so as you come around this foot
establish it whether this energy go
around and grab that foot okay sorry